it's good to have you with us we begin
in india which is reeling from a
militant attack that has killed at least
40 paramilitary police
it is the deadliest attack on security
forces in decades
in the rest of state of jammu and
kashmir in the north
the attack came on a police convoy as it
was traveling on the highway between
jammu and kashmir regions an
explosive-laden car
drove into the convoy at pulvama just
short of the main city of srinagar
pakistan-based terror group jaish
muhammad headed
by this man maulana masood azar has
claimed responsibility for the attack
pakistan has denied any link to the
bombing however
the indian government has withdrawn the
most favored nation status from pakistan
which allowed it to trade on favorable
times with india
prime minister narendra modi has
promised a befitting reply
to those behind the attack
i want to tell the terrorist outfits
and their patrons
that they have committed a huge mistake
[Music]
and they will have to pay a heavy price
for this
so what shape could an indian response
to the attack take
dw correspondent nimisha jaiswal put
that to analyst happy moan jacob
in delhi you know my reading is that
kinetic option um carrying out a
military strike
a surgical small scale ministry strike
against pakistan is a possibility
but that is not without risks um in 2016
september when india did that
um against pakistan the pakistanis
basically said well you know india did
not do anything they were just bluffing
um the reality is that i've done a lot
of work on the line of control and the
reality is that both sides keeps
encroaching into each other's territory
and they sort of carry out small strikes
from time to time and this has gone
unnoticed in the past
but but it was declared to be a proper
strike in 2016 september
and that had its own political
implications now um given the fact that
you announced that in 2016
now you're hi now you are bound to buy
your own past action right i mean you
did that in 2016.
why not now uh especially in the given
the fact that you have an election
coming
which is a prestigious election for mr
modi seeking a second term
um and there are there are people who
say that he is on a weak foot
we wicked at this point of time um so it
is he is
really pressed to the pushed to the
corner um up against a wall
if he does not act um
his his sort of strong mind clearances
will sort of reduce if he acts there
will be retaliation from the other side
um so it's in many ways it's it's a
messy situation um
is the international community going to
push pakistan to the wall are they going
to corner pakistan well the pakis
the pakistanis are actually winning the
war in afghanistan china by their side
russia by their side the americans are
withdrawing uh the trump administration
in in itself in this array um so i think
the international community
uh will not be able to push pakistan
beyond their point so you're looking at
a
a situation where india does india is
not left with too many options
and if it decides to carry out a kinetic
to take the kinetic option it will have
its
repercussions
you